jean lui demandez pas ce que de nombreux
rappeurs pour élargir leur public ils
font ils vont un peu vers la monsieur c
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
3,70 2022 booba sera au stade de france
les séries
qu'est ce que tu vas avoir une petite
race raoul petite angoisse ou pas du
tout toujours toujours c'est vrai c'est
un trac mais c'est un bon track voilà la
peur d'échouer devant comment tu vas
faire pour choisir entre dans tous les
titres que choisir ouais bah ça va
prendre du temps mais c'est ça qui va
être et tous les featuring que tu as
fait comment tu vas faire tu mords faire
tu vas en faire faire une sélection
comme un dj ouais dix albums studio 3
millions d'albums vendus plus de 100
collaboration 100 millions de vues à
chaque fois quatorze albums de platine
c'est un truc de ouf moi j'ai une
question parce qu'ils avaient un
documentaire sur vous sur bfm ya pas
longtemps ils ont évoqué votre fortune
personnelle entre 40 et 60 millions
d'euros est ce que ça vous agace qu'on
parle de votre argent est ce que comme
certains rappeurs américains vous êtes
complètement décomplexé là dessus bah
déjà je sais pas d'où ils ont eu cette
info mais elle est banon qui paradent
moins positive ces
c est pour vous
non c'est pas une fierté je l'aurais je
leur ai pas demandé de faire un truc sur
moi j'ai même refusé quand ils m'ont ils
ont demandé ils ont essayé de
m'interviewer j'ai des noms puisque je
vais le faire moi-même déjà donc ils ont
fait de leur plein gré avec les infos
qu'ils avaient du net c'est ça
[Musique]
damien tard elle est avec nous c'est
incroyable cette image à un moment
qu'est ce qui fait que vous vous dites
je vais mettre une gifle au président je
vous dis hein les gilet jaune sont
exfiltrés ces gens là sont des
travailleurs qui ont parfois deux fois
mon âge qui ont peut-être pris sur le
temps de travail pour être présent ici
et pouvoir s'exprimer ils sont exfiltrés
par la police tout ça pour éviter de
faire tache sur sur des images télé et
d'un président qui en fait en campagne à
leurs frais mais c est à un moment où
vous dites c'était prémédité votre geste
non pas vraiment je vais penser
peut-être cinq minutes avant mais jamais
j'ai pensé qu'il viendrait aussi pressé
minutes avant vous êtes dit que m magic
le président et je suis dit pourquoi pas
si il vient aussi près de nous n'est pas
terrible mais damien vous dit pas un
moment c'est extrêmement grave ce que
j'ai fait
c'est juste une gifle vous avez vu que
le président n'a pas porté plainte oui
oui j'ai été condamné par le préfet de
la drôme qui a démissionné le lendemain
de sa plainte mais bon vous avez vu
quand même que le président n'a pas
porté plainte c'est quand même c'est fou
oui après il a quand même porté plainte
pour une caricature de lui un hitler non
mais là on est moins qu'un peu avisé il
n'a pas porté plainte
oui de la magie d'année à trauma de
prison sans qui porte plainte
non non je n'ai aucun degré n'avait
aucun regret non derrière après il ya
des mots qui vont dire regarde l'autre
il a giflé macron il fait le buzz et des
chanonat et savage et flins polissage à
des notations c'est ça tu es un guignol
mon pote est un guignol moi j'en ai fait
une brèche et
j'ai envie de vous excuser auprès du
président on va écouter ça serait une
double humiliation que de m'excuser lui
avoir mis une gifle quand même
eryl prayer qui nous a rejoints vous
êtes vous êtes chanteur et sosie d'elvis
pressé donc c'est vrai que voilà c'est
le rock'n'roll moi c'est dick rivers et
johnny hallyday eddy mitchell voilà bon
toi
mais en plus
le reste c'est de la merde
des autres nous insulter
[Musique]
qu'il ya des gens il ya des gens qui ont
pris le rap en usage et puis qui sont
mis à divulguer de la haine sur la
société
[Applaudissements]
c'est un avertissement
compris moi ce que c'est qu'un vrai
chanteur
[Applaudissements]
jean
respect parce que le mec qui fait quand
même le stade de france qu'il a vendu
des millions de disques voilà merci ça
reste quand
même un peu tu quittes un peu quoi mais
c'est de la merde quand même
alors sans rien qui maintenant bien sûr
qu'ils n'aiment pas ou je peux tirer la
main sur merci tellement bien faire un
featuring avec lui
merci à
lui demandez pas ce que de nombreux
rappeurs pour élargir leur public ils
font ils vont un peu vers la russie
[Rires]
donc parler de ta carrière c'est
extraordinaire moi souvent je sais que
tes potes et on parle de l'histoire de
l'aéroport et je me dorion suis
tranquille vite nos sociétés si c'était
à refaire parce qu'on sait que c'est pas
toi qui vas l'entretoit temps action tu
vois on sait que c'est pas toi si cet
art fair turbo mon nom mais si c'était à
refaire est-ce que tu referais la même
chose par rapport à maintenant tu as vu
qu'il y avait de le bordel que ça a
foutu les enfants le tout la le circuit
pour être ça je vais discuter au nom des
arts oui j'ai bien kiffé quoi
[Rires]
être parce qu'on a un gardien recrue cas
pas le faire ce soir bagarres dans les
reports et giflé le président est vrai
que voilà il ya eu cet article sur
karine le marchand voilà c'est la fin on
l'a défoncé on a en nous notre mission
en tant que magazine people c'est de
révéler les coulisses de la vie privée
des gens avec tout ce que peuvent en
penser certains tours terme table et
c'est également notre rôle de dévoiler
les coulisses d'une émission alors il va
avec son chauffeur personnel tu toi
comme s'il connaissait les gens depuis
toujours est il qu'il se préparait tout
le monde attend que madame soit prêtre
pendant plus d'une heure sans bouger et
puis quand elle se pointe enfin elle se
regarde dans la caméra et pique une
crise à sa coiffeuse personnelle sa
mèche ne lui convient pas donc elle lui
dit de tout recommencer on attend à
nouveau une heure jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit contente oui ben mes vaches
maintien c'est c'est ce que nous on nous
a raconté un agriculteur et qui a été
confirmé par d'autres puisque la
journaliste qui a fait ce papier on a
rencontré plusieurs alors on le doit
surtout pas lui proposer d'alcool elle
ne veut pas en avoir sous le nez elle ne
mange pas non plus n'importe quoi elle
se commandent ces des menus sans viande
très léger et nous concerne pas les
produits de la ferme semble comprendre
donc voilà elle a une raison personnelle
que je ne pourrais pas dévoiler sur
plateau sans s'en être diffamatoires je
la comprends totalement et je la
respecte nous on l'a pas on n'a pas mis
la raison dans le pavé parce que vous
savez très bien que juridiquement il ya
certaines choses qu'on ne peut pas dire
c'est son droit mais bon on interdira
tout le monde de boire sous ses yeux ses
limites fin juillet un mot qui va
choquer tout le monde mais manif ya
turquois fin schémas sepa fin voilà
c'est quand on est assis que je me
confie sur mon adolescence des piscines
et sur le fait que j'ai pensé au suicide
à cette époque elle à cette petite larme
à l'oeil et quand la productrice unis
c'est bon c'est dans la boîte elle se
lève et rigolent et moi j'étais toujours
assis en train de pleurer oui bah oui
c'est moi certains ego bah oui c'est
c'est vrai c'est ça c'est guillaume l'un
des ses agriculteurs l'un des premiers
agriculteurs enfin le premier
agriculteur homosexuel qu'il raconte
c'est donc donc là et puis ça c'est pour
le coup c'est cette cette citation est
est une est quelque chose qui avait déjà
été publiée dans non ce que je reçois
des sms de plein de journalistes un
autre journaliste jacques arnould fait
une fois karine le marchand à la rentrée
du groupe m6 elle a fait une crise de
nerfs pendant trente minutes contre me
karaman qu'à la caméra n'est pas je
n'étais jamais assez haute la réputation
est vrai et je reçois plein de sms c'est
pas la première fois qu'on entend des
rumeurs ça ne m'étonne pas mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu
un petit classe avec rtl j'ai vu parce
que rtl il est il avait suggéré que vous
vous réconcilier avec l'usure fait leur
campagne de pub la lie clarisse et c'est
vrai que tu es tu réponds à tout le
monde parce qu il utilise mon pour le
buzz mais derrière et passe pas ma
musique ouais c'est vraiment sur rdl
vous réveiller des gens là
sur rtl vous passionnés du bois parce
qu'elle est quand même moi je pense que
non mais je suis pas décisionnaire mais
tu penses que sur rtl - seaway away sur
rtl du booba way we sur moi je me sens
commenté c'est ce qui l'aurait fait
depuis 27 ans
si on voit de 7 ans ils sont pas rêver
mais j'ai évolué comme en plus vous là
vous avez dit que vous viendriez si non
mais passent pas de rap
qu'il adorait oui il s'était alors
tellement qu'il me joue pas
je suis pas dans le secret des dieux
mais je sais que c'est à l'étude mais la
preuve ou lentilles le visa
d'études à faire sur un album ce numéro
1 est une radio tu me passes mais attend
et je ne peux pas essayer pas séduire
quelques points demain adieu booba
demain sur la scène sans relâche et te
dire comment serait
allé super
immédiatement avec cet extrait du titre
dragon
lang arrosée
c'est pas compétent annoncé cession par
ge c'est l'une des plus belles tests que
j'ai déjà le croquerait bien avec un
trio
julien courbet a passé le titre en
intégralité en rappelant le contexte fm
pas regarder bon à l'extrême
booba nous dit bah oui mais vous
utilisez mon image sur les affiches
alors qu'on ne passe pas mais disent que
sur rtl mais simon booba on les passait
c'est une grande première pour la
première fois booba sur rtl le voici
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
prend les gens qui s'en vont donc
certains portables des mois mais il a
fait ce qu une vision de monsieur
division exige à ce que monsieur
division et donc au dessus des lois il
exige que les chroniqueurs et en plus de
leurs passes à me taire un test bêta
leur jeu précis non absolument pas
pardon maintenant j'ai pas accepter
parce que j'ai un masque mais attendez
ça c'est ça c'est une blague mais non
excusez-moi le producteur maintenant que
tout le monde c'était tester non ok ça
ne marche pas
ça pwned de mensonge mais non pas la
production m'a menti la moitié de
terrain pas menti théo théo théo
rochelle
thomas dit
j'ai dit moi
ça drôle jamais ce qu'il rate c'est gras
trouve ça dingue drôle de mentir un
chroniqueur je vais rien négliger la
preuve j'ai des sms ou jeudi ce soir je
viens dehors si tu veux que je vienne et
il m'a dit non tous les chroniqueurs se
font tester et vendredi derniers temps
quelqu'un n'est ce pas à mes vingt douze
derniers mois j'ai dit je reste dehors
il m'a dit non oui effectivement c'est
souvent tout se fait à prier c'est
du mépris sans nom
finition
[Musique]
sport lés paris mais moi je veux dire
concrètement non je suis désolé on joue
pas avec ça mais c'est ça que vous
foutez de ma gueule vous paraît que ça
joue pas ces règles sanitaires mondiales
et
une migraine pas du tout la grille à
temps
plein à dire en plateau mais accord et
effectivement quand tu me dis que tous
les chroniqueurs se font tester et que
c'est la raison pour laquelle on était
content de revenir voir booba il a
accepté de revenir que vous veniez c'est
sympa
je vais alors est-ce que vous avez très
vite il excella dans la fois jeté un peu
vexé et enfin j'ai pas compris pourquoi
on pourrai pas débattre normal des
débats j'ai déjà une peu de questions à
lui poser pourquoi avez maintenant je ne
discute pas avec vous mais pourquoi je
voudrais mais voilà vous dis voilà vous
que vous lisez ce que qu elle ressortie
vous avez là vers fois parce que chez
vous avez été un petit peu vexé mais le
ressenti c'est quelqu'un qui veut pas
discuter qui a peut-être peur de 10 ans
mais vous avez de ses députés on n'a pas
parlé de moi vous avez des choses à dire
quand j'ai voulu parler m'a dit et je
parle pas été discutée raciste bon j'ai
c'est d'abord c'est pas vrai en débat
moi j'ai passé des millions de personnes
souffrent mois donc à des millions de
personnes racistes mon impression à
l'aller rennes sera heureuse de le
dollar c'est ce qu'il dégage de toi de
tes tweet d'accord et quentin avec la
merde mais quand tu écris ou aimons
maghreb où sont mes negro c'est pas
raciste non
c'est la négrophobie c'est du racisme
que son micro vous diriez negro vous
laissant derrière toi
voilà voilà donc là c'est bien parce que
je voulais vous parliez ce soir parce
qu'il a il avait été vexé voilà donc
comme c'est juste ça ouais ouais non
voilà c'est pour ça qu'il est tombé sur
narcisse et moi je n'attaque jamais la
personne mais vous vous n'êtes
qu'hypocrisie là vous défendez des idées
en coulisse vous est même loin de ces
idées là vous n'avez aucune sincères il
affirmé regardez vos costumes ridicules
et les connais
pas du tout je vous expliquez vous
n'avez pas regardé des bourses en blanc
a fait semblant d'avoir des costumes bas
de gamme que vous portez pour avoir
l'air populaire
non mais ça c'est pas bien riche verdès
voulait en fait vous n'êtes que n vous
transpirez l'art et tous mes sens noble
art et vous avez les yeux révulsés la
gamme des lèvres vous et que vous
exhaler vous exhaler une forme de haine
je vous parle parce que je vous ai fait
pour faire ça écoutez moi je pense
qu'effectivement les idées c'est une
chose l'être humain en est une autre
brouillés ougandaise est ce que vous
dites pardon à genlis yahoo est ce que
vous lui dites me com ou qui on aura la
réponse de jean-michel juste après mais
je lui dis jamais pardon je leur ai dit
nico mots que jean médias
boucard
huit familles comique
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une histoire une histoire
conseils de tous à peu près depuis
plusieurs mois d'action est évident que
ça allait sortir toutes les saloperies
sont autorisés dont celle là qu'il ya ça
il n'y a pas de sa lola je vous écoute
avec beaucoup de patience avec votre
petit air goguenard ouais il souriant de
remuer la merde puisque c'est votre
métier d'ailleurs je vais vous dire que
c'est un geste que vous êtes sérieux
avec votre femme tous les gens qui l'ont
vu se promener sur le port de toulon est
alors qu'ils ont fait défaut et alors
c'est la même chose que ça et le
journaliste me suis dit waouh le montrer
vous êtes un journalise le maire
d'essayer
ça provoque chez moi un dégoût
chimiquement pur jeu c'est votre ami
tous les moyens d'avoir une amie mais
tous les moyens sont bons maintenant
pour abattre un homme alors je mens il a
réagi et jeté en pâture une femme à
l'opinion publique se confond le
reportage ne porte pas sur eric zemmour
elle porte sur cette conseillère le
politique ou même eric zemmour se
prépare à ça il sait que c'est varié
mais les proches c'est ça c'est
l'épreuve les proches téléphoner jamais
préparé à ça c'est donc cédé gueule
alors fake n'est pas paradis sont aux
journalistes que les eaux usées sont à
l'eau courante adacore 7000 quoi trouver
non mais c'est bien les égouts et les
égouts c'est les journaux que dirige
m'adapte mais vous n'êtes pas dans le
genre et le rapport non plus totalement
irréprochable j'ai publié des photos de
vous ben les publier des photos nous
avait parlé l'orientation sexuelle de
certaines personnes et des procès pour
ça donc vous pouvez faire ligne auront
fait que c'est de la diffamation oui
d'accord je n'ai jamais parlé
l'orientation qui compte déjà mieux que
vous dites c'est un mensonge et je ne le
cache pas comme vous comme un lâche dans
l'ombre bon c'est sûr qu'on parle pas
je vous dis je
cevital qui monte au créneau parce que
series et moi je n'ai jamais entendu
hurler au loup avant l'affairé mots et
l'âge méthodes pacifiques niveau des
paparazzades dégueulasse il y en a eu
pas mal écouté mais vous avez dit le
stream est sûre griveaux je me suis
exprimé sur des tas de gens tu te
trompes et vous qui commençaient à
lancer des accusations complètement
fantaisie sur un procès pour orientation
sexualité renseignez-vous ouais bien sûr
renseignez-vous non contaminées dont les
retourneurs autour change
par les autres ou non est ce que
maintenant non j'allais vous calmer
parce que bon la
minute
lancé des accusés
me bien sûr on oublie tout et on jette
très intelligent et nous nous sommes
très idiot on a bien compris votre
message merci beaucoup à tous mais vous
n'avez pas l'air devrions
donc nous en tant que journée à disputer
nous révélons sa vie privée parce que
c'est à people c'est vous qui transforme
et ça nous fasse plutôt que tu fais ce
que je veux
aller aux couvertures ok c'est mon
pantalon devant devant annoncer quoi
bien s'il vous plaît aux enfants
jean michel maire avant c'est le
chroniqueur le plus ancien
jean michel maire
c'est un ami ah bon quelqu'un que j'aime
abo même si je vous ai jamais prêter
d'argent
c'est plus que prêter disons d'affaires
c'est plus que prêter de l'argent
michel we
quittez-vous laventure tpm p
si oui votre réponse et votre décision
sera irrévocable
ne fais pas le con j'ai bien réfléchi
c'est un raccourci c'est pas que je n'ai
pas ma place mais il ya tellement
d'autres qui ont ils méritent leur place
et qu'ils sont bien ici qui me font rire
tous les soirs quand je les regarde que
c'est peut-être le moment mes enfants
sont grands c'est peut-être le moment de
partir j'ai des envies d'ailleurs voilà
comme comme beaucoup de gens à 60 ans
c'est peut-être le moment j'ai de la
famille en asie j'adore l'asie j'adore
larchitecture nazi notamment
si je voyais à roissy c'est que j'arrête
tpm paix mais je ne suis pas encore à
roissy
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sortir à tout moment même et donc mais
donc pour l'instant vous êtes là je suis
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
desigual je suis là quand vous m'invitez
vous n'arrêtez pas jamais d'amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]